what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to create something
special that will change the planet so
to help you on your journey I started to
mentor me series and the goal here is to
try to hang around people who've done a
lot more than us who achieved massive
success and hopefully by hanging around
them a little bit longer some of their
mindsets their attitudes their beliefs
the way they see the world will seep in
to us to help us become the best version
of ourselves so today we're going to
learn from jordan peterson and some of
his most amazing moments mentor me
Jordan
[Music]
you
my experience is with people that were
probably running at about 51% of our
capacity something mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates how many hours a day you
waste or how many hours a week you waste
and the classic answer is something like
4 to 6 hours a day
you know inefficient studying watching
things on YouTube that not only do you
not want to watch that you don't even
care about that make you feel horrible
about watching after you're done that's
probably four hours right there know
what you think well that's 2025 hours a
week it's a hundred hours a month that's
two and a half full work weeks it's half
a year of work weeks per year and if
your time is worth twenty dollars an
hour which is a radical under estimate
it's probably more like 50 if you think
about it in terms of deferred wages if
you're wasting 20 hours a week
you're wasting $50,000 a year and you
are doing that right now and it's
because you're young wasting $50,000 a
year is a way bigger catastrophe than it
would be for me to waste it because I'm
not gonna last nearly as long and so if
your life isn't everything it could be
you could ask yourself well what would
happen if you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts well and if we all got our act
together collectively and stop making
things worse because that's another
thing people do all the time not only do
they not do what they should to make
things better they actively attempt to
make things worse because they're
spiteful or resentful or arrogant or
deceitful or or homicidal or genocide
allure all of those things all bundled
together in an absolutely pathological
package if people start really really
trying just to make things worse we have
no idea how much better they would get
just because of that you're actually
tougher than you think you never knew
that and maybe you didn't want to take
on the responsibility because you know
people play a role in their own demise
so to speak when you had opportunity to
go out and explore or
with draw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
over protected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the fact
that you were over protected and run
back there whenever you had the
opportunity you know so maybe you're a
kid in the playground right and you're
having some trouble with other kids and
you know in the back of your mind I
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene and you know that
that's not right
you know that you're breaking the social
contract but it's easier and so that's
what you do you run off to an authority
figure and hide behind the Great Father
right roughly speaking well the problem
with that is you don't learn how to do
it yourself so then you have to relearn
it painfully when you're 40 so then you
take people out you say well what are
you afraid of rank it from 1 to 10 so 10
is what make a list of 10 things you're
afraid of the least the thing you're
least afraid of will call number 10 so
we'll start with that
okay well I'm afraid of elevators okay
well let's let's look at a picture of an
elevator let's have you imagine being in
an elevator let's go out to an elevator
and let you watch the terrible jaws of
death open because that's how you're
responding to it symbolically right and
you're gonna do that at it at the the
closest proximity you can manage you
find out you go do that it works you're
nervous as hell especially at it from an
anticipatory perspective shaking you go
out you stop you watch it happen and you
actually calm down you do that 10 times
it no longer bothers you well what
you've learned that you didn't die but
more importantly than that you've
learned that you could withstand the
threat of death that's what you've
learned and then you move a little
closer and then you move a little closer
and then you move a little closer and
finally you're back in what's no longer
the elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
hmm
turns out I can withstand that and then
you're met much more together much more
confident and that's often one of the
things that often happens in situations
like that I've seen this multiple times
is that if you run someone through an
exposure training process like that and
toughen them up they'll often start Stan
up to people around them in a way they
never did before stop doing the things
that you know are wrong that you could
stop doing right so it's it's a fairly
it's a fairly limited attempt first of
all we're not going to say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense but we will presume
that there are things that you're doing
that for one reason or another you know
are not in your best interests there's
something about them that you just know
you should stop they're kind of
self-evident to you other things you're
gonna be doubtful about you're not gonna
know which way is up and which way is
down but there are things that you're
doing that you know you shouldn't do now
some of those you won't stop doing for
whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or you don't believe it's
necessary or it's too much of a
sacrifice or you're angry or resentful
or or afraid who knows so forget about
those for now but there's another subset
that you could stop doing it might be
little thing well that's fine stop doing
it and see what happens and what will
happen is your vision will clear a
little bit and then something else will
pop up in your field of apprehension
that you will also know you should stop
doing and that you could stop doing
because you've strengthened yourself a
bit by stopping doing the particular
stupid thing that you were doing before
that just puts you together a little bit
more and you could do that repeatedly
for for an indefinite period of time and
and you know that doesn't necessarily
mean that you're going to ever be able
to formulate a clear and final picture
of what constitutes the truth and the
good but it does mean that you'll be
able to continually move away from
what's untruth and what's bad and you
know well that's not a bad start no one
can live without a routine you just
forget that if you guys don't have a
routine I would recommend like you get
one going because you cannot be mentally
healthy without a routine you need to
pick a time to get up whatever time you
want but pick one and stick to it
because otherwise you dis regulate your
circadian rhythms and they regulate your
mood and eat something in the morning I
had lots of clients who've had anxiety
disorders I had one client who was
literally starving very small
girl she there's very little that she
liked she kind of tried to subsist on
like half a cup of rice a day she came
to me and said I have no energy I come
home all I want to do is watch the same
movie over and over what like is that
weird and I thought well it depends on
how hard you work you know it's a little
weird but whatever it's familiar and
you're looking for comfort so I did an
analysis of her diet it's like three
quarters of a cup of rice it's like
you're starving eat something
you know you'll feel better
so she modified her diet and her all her
anxiety went away and she had some
energy it's like yeah you got to eat so
schedule now that's a good thing man
your brain will thank you for it it will
stabilize your nervous system with it's
a bit of a plan that's a good thing well
if you're harmless you're not virtuous
you're just harmless you're like a
rabbit rabbit isn't virtuous it's just
just can't do anything except get eaten
it's not virtuous if you're a monster
and you don't act monstrously then
you're virtuous but you also have to be
a monster while you see this all the
time Harry Potter's like that too it's
like he's he's flawed he's hurt he's got
evil in him he can talk to snakes man he
breaks rules all the time all the time
he's not at obedient at all but you know
he has a good reason for breaking the
rules and if he couldn't break the rules
him and his little clique of rule
breaking you know troublemakers if they
didn't break the rules
they wouldn't attain the highest goal so
it's very peculiar but it's it's very
there it's a very very very very common
mythological notion you know the hero
has to be the hero has to be a monster
but a controlled monster Batman is like
that you know I mean it's it's
everywhere it's it's the Tor story you
always hear I started to pay very
careful attention to what I was saying I
don't know if that happened voluntarily
or involuntarily but I could feel a sort
of split developing in my psyche and the
split and I've actually had students
tell me the same thing has
to them after they've listened to some
of the material that that I've been
describing to all of you but split into
two let's say and one part was the let's
say the old me that was talking a lot
and that liked to argue and that liked
ideas and there was another part that
was watching that part like just with
its eyes open and neutrally judging and
the part that was neutrally judging was
watching the part that was talking and
going that isn't your idea you don't
really believe that you don't really
know what you're talking about that
isn't true and I thought hmm that's
really interesting so now I've and that
was happening to like 95% of what I was
saying and so then I didn't really know
what to do I thought okay this is
strange so maybe I've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all I
mean it wasn't like I was hearing voices
or anything like that I mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people have multiple
parts so then I had this weird conundrum
it's like well which of those two things
are me is it the part that's listening
and saying no that's rubbish that's a
lie that's you're doing that to impress
people you're just trying to win the
argument you know was that me or was the
part that was going about my normal
verbal business me and I didn't know but
I decided I would go with the critic and
then what I'd tried to do what I learned
to do I think was to stop saying things
that made me weak and now that I mean
I'm still trying to do that because I'm
always feeling when I talk whether or
not the words that I'm saying are either
making me align or making me come apart
and I think the alignment I really do
think the alignment is it I think
alignment is the right way of
conceptualizing it because I think if
you say things that are as true as you
can say them let's say then they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your sub structure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you
to speak from the core of your being we
don't understand any of that we don't
even conceptualize that but I believe
that you can feel that and I learned
some of that from reading Carl Rogers by
the way who's a great clinician because
he talked about mental health in part as
the coherence between the the the
spiritual or the or the abstract and the
physical that the two things were
aligned and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in psychoanalytic and clinical
thinking but anyways I decided that I
would start practicing not saying things
that would make me weak and what
happened was that I had to stop saying
almost everything that I was saying I
would say 95% of it as a hell of a shark
to wake up and I mean this was over a
few months but it's a hell of a shark to
wake up and realize that you're mostly
dead wood it's a shark
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little hosk
it's like well if that 5% is solid then
maybe that's exactly what you want to
have happen thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or your business
what was the single most important
lesson that you learned leave it down in
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to surge wisdom thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and for doing multiple
reviews on the book for each chapter you
can go check it out in this channel I
really I really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the
[Applause]
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]